since you're so attached to them you
should know at the equinox i will begin
the destruction remaking of the humans
their infighting their wars they've
become petty creatures of violence
their blood is spilled in waste on the
battlefield rather than given to us
their nobility and usefulness has waned
we've remade humanity four times before
did it really help them or us
god repellent obsidian remarkable
ironic that we wiped out the best of our
creations
we can't operate the old mech devices
anyway they're all made of this
so let's make a benefit i'll use a human
to close the five gates a pet
before the equinox there's no possible
way a human can not only that
i'll choose the lowest of the low to do
it
even the most pathetic can prove their
worth
hmm i don't trust you a compromise then
you'll use one of my emissaries to guide
the human to ensure there's no trickery
who's your most loyal emissary
yeah and the stakes
our lives whoever wins gets the blood
sacrifices of the other
i'll take your bet who shall be your
lowest of the low
oh you'll see humanity's champion
is nearly ready
you